malgré son titre la chute de l'empiré
américain de denys arcand n'a rien à
voir avec son grand film le déclin de
l'empiré américain ou sa suite les
invasions barbares
dans ce nouveau film de denys arcand
nous raconte l'histoire d'un docteur en
philosophie devenu livreur de colis
ce philosophe qui se dit très
intelligent pose tout de même un geste
très irrationnel spectateurs d'une
fusillade meurtrière
il décide sur le coup de s'enfuir avec
deux sacs remplis de billets de banque
ce trottoir comme un criminel et voici
ce que nous avons aimé le jeu des
acteurs marie-pier morin dans son rôle
d' escort perce littéralement l'écran
dès sa prestation et sans fausse note
rémy girard est très bon dans son rôle
de motards sortie de prison sont ok
juste percutant travail et tertiaire
curieux aussi est solide incarne avec
force son avocat qui a peu de scrupules
nous avons aussi aimé la cinématographie
denys arcand film à montréal comme nul
autre
utilisant la lumière et l'espace avec
maîtrise totale de la gamme de l'ouest
c'est pas des arabes mais voici ce qui
apparaît moins réussi le scénario
cette critique de l'argent et du pouvoir
utilise trop de raccourcis souvent le
récit apparaît vraisemblable exemple
difficile de croire à cette histoire
d'amour entre des scores que de luxe et
un livreur de colis philosophe
difficile aussi de croire à ce monde
corrompu qu'on nous présente souvent
sans nuances qu'on peut dire que notre
spécial
un déficit comme la chute de l'empiré
américain n'est certainement pas aussi
faible que le règne de la beauté ou
encore l'âge des ténèbres mais nous
avons l'impression d'être loin des
oeuvres marquantes réalisées par denis
auguin
comme son fameux jésus de montréal qui
avait toujours été un homme est où ils
nous apprennent rien tout gage ici wifi
dépouillement